[Musica]
qualche volta mi capita di immaginare
una cosa è appunto il giorno in cui
tantissimi anni fa l'uomo per la prima
volta appena oltre la linea delle
colline conobbe un'immensa creatura
d'acqua e quella creatura d'acqua
c'erano volte in cui era calma e piatta
volte in cui si increspa va quando
soffiava la brezza altre volte in cui
con un rombo di tuono si scagliava
rabbiosa contro la scogliera
ecco per la prima volta quel giorno
l'uomo aveva scoperto il mare che da
quel giorno lo attrae e lo respinge e
causa in lui grappoli di emozioni
positive quanto oscure ancestrali paure
ci vollero moltissimi anni perché l'uomo
trovasse il coraggio di soul carli quei
mai ad opera di popoli come i vichinghi
o i fenici e di personalità più avanti
come cristoforo colombo magellano
amerigo vespucci e se vogliamo stare qui
a parlare di quanto spazio di
riflessione l'uomo si sia preso prima di
immergersi in quei mari
questo discorso e rischierebbe di durare
fin troppo perché i primi tentativi di
immersione in apnea sono registrate
attorno al ix secolo avanti cristo
tuttavia io non sono qui oggi per
condurre un trattato storico
sull'esplorazione dei fondali marini
perché forse questa è una cosa che è
stata fatta fin troppe volte
oggi io sono qui per parlarvi di una
branca specifica di quella esplorazione
che è forse la sfida all'ignoto per
eccellenza ovvero l'immersione subacquea
con autorespiratore al giorno d'oggi
in italia si contano circa 5.000
subacquei brevettati ciò significa che
queste persone hanno seguito un corso di
formazione e ottenuto un attestato di
competenza
dati alla mano significa che nel nostro
paese una persona su 12 mila accesso a
quello che el ambiente subacqueo e le
restanti 11.999 rimangono
l'uso e dall esplorazione dei fondali
che si badi occupano il 70 per cento
della superficie terrestre
tuttavia l'attività subacquea nella
testa delle persone è legata a un
repertorio di bellissime immagini
immagini che possiamo vedere tutti i
giorni nei film honey documentari
la verità è che nel momento in cui ci si
trova a dover passare dal sogno
alimentato da quelle immagini alla vera
e propria pratica dell'attività è come
un brusco risveglio
anch'io fino a qualche anno fa associavo
l'immagine di un subacqueo semplicemente
alla flessuosa figura umana che bombola
in spalle pinne piedi si bea
dell'assenza di gravità e del tempo
sospeso in quei bellissimi luoghi
la verità è che ignoravo e forse la
maggior parte di voi ignora ciò che c'è
dietro quell'immagine di serenità la
verità è che dietro quell'immagine c'è
un allenamento durissimo di tipo fisico
e anche teorico perché c'è anche una
parte teorica della della preparazione e
la verità è che nella sua sfida
all'ignoto un subacqueo si espone a
tutta una gamma di rischi rischi che
vanno minimizzati tramite la cura
maniacale del dettaglio
allora a questo punto forse vi starete
chiedendo perché sfidare l'ignoto e
perché pagare per farlo
ecco io nei prossimi dieci minuti
tenterò di farvi capire cosa significa
un'attività come la subacquea
innanzitutto essa è un'immensa scuola
d'amore verso se stessi dopo di che vi
spiegherò come questa attività può
essere una scuola d'amore per la natura
e infine come può essere una scuola
d'amore verso gli altri
mi rendo conto che è una risposta
difficile da dare è difficile per me da
formulare e forse per voi in parte da
comprendere la la causa principale di
questa difficoltà diciamo è il fatto che
parlando di questo argomento forse noi
subacquei tendiamo a dare per scontato
sensazioni ed emozioni che non sono
affatto comuni
perché appartengono ad un mondo che lo
vogliamo o meno è un mondo che ci
resterà sempre estraneo tuttavia il
nostro obiettivo è il mio obiettivo oggi
qua non è quello di comprendere a fondo
questo mondo
quanto più quello di farvi capire la
bellezza e gli insegnamenti che esso ha
da offrirci
innanzitutto c'è da dire che per me
l'immersione sott'acqua è una sorta di
ritorno a casa perché la maggior parte
di voi lo saprà si sa che la vita ha
avuto origine nell'acqua e quindi questo
ritorno nell'acqua è una sorta di
richiamo radicato nel nostro dna e che
poi è stato inibito nel corso dei secoli
a causa del timore reverenziale che
l'uomo prova nei confronti del mare
ecco e prima stavo parlando del rapporto
che esiste tra l'uomo e il mare
questo rapporto è un rapporto
sostanzialmente ambivalente che è fatto
di due polarità e queste due polarità
sono l'attrazione e la diffidenza quando
mi immergo devo superare la diffidenza
ma senza cedere incondizionatamente
all'attrazione infatti se ho paura o se
non mi sento bene non mi immergo ma se
decido di mettere il guinzaglio alle mie
paure e di immergermi non devo cedere
incondizionatamente a quello che posso
definire in modo ironico il canto delle
sirene ovvero a non abbandonare la
sicurezza affascinata da quei luoghi
ecco se la se l'acceleratore e
l'attrazione la diffidenza deve essere
sempre il freno e per far ciò il
controllo razionale di sé è il primo
degli strumenti infatti la sfida
all'ignoto non deve essere mai una sfida
alla propria incolumità
infatti sott'acqua più che in ogni altro
luogo si percepisce la sacralità della
propria vita e la necessità di tutelarla
con tutti i comportamenti necessari
proprio perché in quel luogo noi siamo
degli ospiti non è casa nostra
in questo senso ovvero appunto
riscoprendo il rapporto tra l'uomo e il
mare
facendomi rendere conto dei miei limiti
e ancora facendomi rendere conto di
quanto un sentimento come quello della
paura è importante la subacquea mi ha
aiutato a riscoprire me stessa infatti
quando uno sport come questo aiuta una
persona a realizzare appieno il proprio
potenziale
si può proprio definire una scuola
d'amore verso se stessi
lo è anche perché ha un immenso effetto
catartico ad ogni metro che io percorro
verso il fondo quando mi immergo
allontanandomi dalla mia quotidianità è
un metro che percorro immergendomi in un
mondo fatto di sensazioni colorate e
gratificanti che prima ancora di
fluttuare mi davanti agli occhi mi
fluttuano nella testa insomma faccio
pace con la vita e sono felice di
esserci in questa vita
in secondo luogo soprattutto se è
correttamente gestita la subacquea è una
grandissima scuola d'amore verso la
natura
quando mi ritrovo a scivolare tra i
coralli olea tini e o quando mi ritrovo
in un banco di meduse o una murena si
affaccia dalla sua tana guardandomi
minacciosa
o ancora mi guida tutta attorno un banco
di sgombri io mi sento intimamente parte
di quel piccolo angolo di mondo e mi
sento investita del compito di
proteggerlo
purtroppo capita molto più spesso di
quanto voi crediate di trovare una busta
che galleggia tra le onde oppure una
macchia d'olio a pochi metri dalla riva
o ancora ci sono fondali che sono
costellati di bottiglie vuote e
copertoni d'auto rifiuti che sono lì da
così tanto tempo che lo stesso ambiente
sembra essersi rassegnato alla loro
presenza
ecco è frustrante vedere come l'uomo
spesso si dimentica che questo mondo ci
è stato dato in comodato d'uso e che non
siamo gli unici proprietari della terra
che calpestiamo ci sono altri esseri ci
sono specie in pericolo ecosistemi in
crescita foreste laghi che meritano lo
stesso rispetto che noi diamo così
ciecamente ai nostri pari e se non si
avesse la forza o semplicemente la
voglia di pensare a questi altri esseri
come minimo bisognerebbe pensare alla
generazione che verrà dopo di noi alle
persone come noi a cui noi dovremo
consegnare questo mondo con un
ecosistema che ancora come minimo si
possa definire tale in modo che essi
possano viverci in tranquillità infine
stavo dicendo all'inizio che la
subacquea è un'immensa scuola d'amore
verso gli altri
non so se lo sapete ma nel caso sarà una
delle cose che imparerete oggi ma i
subacquei per regola sono obbligati
almeno ad immergersi in coppia e quindi
anche la maggior parte degli esercizi
che portiamo avanti e si fanno in coppia
e devo ammetterlo tra due persone in
questo campo c'è un rapporto di fiducia
reciproca che è veramente rassicurante
in realtà alle persone normali forse
questa cosa potrà suonare un po strana
perché si tratta di affidare
completamente la propria sicurezza nelle
mani di una persona che forse per i
primi tempi addirittura un estraneo
e siccome per la maggior parte della
nostra vita viviamo secondo il motto
fidarsi è bene ma non fidarsi è meglio
allora forse per le persone normali
sembra quasi un incubo
diciamo affidare la propria vita nelle
mani di un estraneo
eppure per noi subacquee un certo punto
succede qualcosa di magico
questo legame di sostegno che c'è
sott'acqua fuori dall'acqua si tramuta
in un legame d'amicizia che è uno dei
più veri e sinceri che io abbia mai
incontrato nel corso della mia
esperienza
cioè io oggi non sarei qui se non ci
fossero sempre stati i miei compagni
membri del mio club a sostenermi in ogni
mio progetto e è proprio grazie a loro
che io posso portare su questo palco
oggi questi insegnamenti
infatti mi hanno fatto anche dono
diciamo di queste bellissime fotografie
che state vedendo proiettate sulle slide
e appunto io a distanza di anni posso
dire che i loro insegnamenti mi hanno
veramente cambiato la vita perché hanno
cambiato il mio modo di vedere le cose
infatti tramite la subacquea ho imparato
che anche il più grande dei problemi ciò
che pensiamo sia la cosa che
riusciremo mai ad affrontare con calma e
sangue freddo si riesce ad affrontare ed
è uno dei più begli insegnamenti che io
abbia mai avuto
infatti per concludere oggi io spero di
essere riuscita almeno a passarvi uno
dei messaggi di cui appunto ho parlato
nel mio discorso e mi rendo conto che è
una cosa difficile perché la subacquea è
uno sport che tutti noi vediamo in
televisione né documentario nei film ma
poche persone possono dire di conoscere
fino in fondo è tuttavia al di là dei
singoli sport al di là dei singoli casi
per riprendere il discorso che stavo
facendo all'inizio il messaggio
importante di quello che io vi voglio
dire è che non bisogna mai avere paura
di quello che può esserci al di là di
quella collina di cui stavamo parlando
all'inizio del discorso e molto spesso
non riusciamo a vedere una strada o
neanche a qualcosa che somiglia un
sentiero per superarla però quando
riusciremo a farlo tutti i nostri sforzi
saranno ricompensati perché le cose che
si trovano al di là dei nostri più
grandi limiti sono le più belle proprio
perché sono nascoste e appunto per me
questo passo di riscoperta di me stessa
è stata la subacquea
ma so che per altre persone può essere o
qualunque altra cosa
e infatti ci tengo a dire per chiunque
non avesse ancora trovato la sua strada
segui il tuo cuore senza riserve e non
avere mai paura di affrontare ciò che
c'è nelle lande sconosciute perché a
questo punto posso dirlo
la sfida all ignoto è un'esperienza che
ti regala a tantissimi doni e sono tutti
i doni di immenso valore grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]